were so full podcast welcome to the
what's up ooh podcast with Felipe
Esparza and the co-host of the year
Rodrigo Torres yeah man how's the young
man podcast doing good for 26 episodes
the new episode be up tomorrow which
will be Saturday and your room is still
going on there Romano's on Wednesday
night Riverside in downtown LA on
University Drive yeah yeah on University
Avenue right there between lime and
orange and that's every Wednesday night
what's up fool you got missed out man
last week I was at Romano's showed up
with the Birdman to try a couple of new
jokes it was awesome Pop's was there her
bro AC was there Birdman was there I
don't know who I was there but they were
they left
thanks for coming through those it was
fun man I live dog it's all good man you
know you go from doing a bunch of shows
that are at the improv you know where
it's set up you know you know it's set
up you know for a comedy club times y is
time you know there's a time level of
our comedy story like the combinatorial
problem you know everybody has a certain
time they're gonna get off on right so
I'll controlling the waitress walking
around but mad so a lot of times I did a
bar it's not like a bar but like all
that the House of Blues on a Monday so
when up there have a most of them grab a
Buddha gloves over there
yeah do they're always there as you
showed up that day she's got data
there's a special event they had a lot
of questions nobody's be oh thank you
baby was there we would be Umbro of
Oakland so yeah although Ole Miss with a
new single bro this was breaking music
no breaking news he wasn't there though
yeah
oh boy you deliver he's in Arizona yeah
a Red Bull head bull headed right across
the street from Laughlin Laughlin and
what next to have us is that little
tri-state area what's a good area man if
you have the cash you know everything
- like you have cash coming in all the
time we know you got royalties you got
something coming in bro because if
you're there you know the person who's
trying to make a living and doing the
best I can but non-stop right hell yeah
dog desert community what kind of jobs
do they have I don't know like what like
boat mechanic see do mechanic farming
cactus or something that was a catch
solar farms food what off casinos full
right that's why I play the word a
letter aleph of hotel and cleaning jobs
there you go and then they have that
rush from like the you would spring
break is wouldn't everybody come to the
river summertime summertime like what's
up fool we have a guest today man
hopefully he'll be here later on man I'm
am I about here man
he knows our you know he knows us from
day one actually day with day two week
three
Martine more air no you know what uh
there fool um he'd been Torre was
Gabriel is here now for like 12 years
yeah way over a decade where were a
decade almond we we knew multimode air
no we're numb he first started off I
forgot where we met how where I met him
the first time but I'm I'm pretty sure
we'll get to that and I met I wish we
had at least five hours to talk to this
guy man perfect we're even again but I
won't even get to the part about him
touring with Gabriel cook this guy's
more he's gonna interesting man himself
we meet yeah may as a big toe of death
and I I think on a spit on my water no I
think he's kidding at me or I can't have
him you guys kidnapping to each other
dogs yeah man whether it was a coup
adventures in babysitting that was my
embroidery but we went our own movies oh
I get Road dogs if you're loaded in
Oxford hahaha would you be much I turn
on the Harley me son Chris's I guess you
got it like that is what I get to all
the stories that a pianist even a set up
a on stage a razor set up at that razor
set up with a fake dog and also um
waiting for the long hair every night we
read a book called we read the same book
bro call random family so whatever that
was I'm a cold sore bro it's an awesome
book if anybody out
and looking for a book to UM encourage
your daughter or your son to continue to
move forward and get nobody pregnant and
you know pretty much slow of life read
this book it's called random family this
book is based up on uh it was like
reality show before a reality show
this woman she lived with the Puerto
Rican family in the Bronx during the
time and she wrote it all down broken
the book is dated two to nineteen ninety
Wyndham Tyson first got arrested
oh wow ever he did juvenile time oh yeah
as a kid during those times when I'm
talking with my tyson was locked up one
of the characters in the book was locked
up with him and it tells Mike Tyson I
get the they got both over time I think
Mike Tyson was locked up for that um for
that rape charge
okay so that was after I already became
he got out of nineteen ninety something
right yeah and that's after the old man
died that's kind of at the beginning of
the downward spiral
yeah 1993 was it or ready for something
like that dude well there's a big heroin
addict [ __ ] a big heroin dealer in the
in the book called um they call him Boy
George and he was like a big drug dealer
man I think a New Jack city
the way he the way Wesley Snipes Randa
the crack apartment in that his movie I
know anyway based on that Puerto Rican
guy named Boy George Nino brown yeah cuz
he that fool had our Empire of [ __ ]
heroin Empire and in in the Bronx and
queens in all that area because a lot of
people were jumping into crack cocaine
at the time and Boy George decided while
everybody getting into crack she's gonna
just focus on heroin so became a big
heroin dealer and he's one of the
character that's in the book and we run
into on Boy George in that book random
family because I'm his girlfriend baby
mama has a cousin named mom Coco Coco
and the whole book is based on this
Puerto Rican young girl who had a baby
when she was like 14 or 15
and then and like the turmoil and the
heartaches that she went through with
that baby you know like the hard times
but I live it and welfare and I happy
welfare and living the streets and your
man being locked up and her whole family
man just man you keep reading the book
you know like so books you keep reading
and you keep thinking the book is gonna
get better for these people life is
gonna get better nah man
life keeps getting worse there's no
scene in this book we'll talk about it
with Marty Moreno and I felt like my MA
Martine laughed because one of the guys
in the book he wears like a big
settlement dog and he just
they spend all that money on parting and
I feel just by everybody leather jackets
brother Bernardo so not only the
chameleon band Adam for reading comedian
he showed up one time to a comedy show
with his lady
never wearing a black leather hat black
[ __ ] leather pants black jacket black
shirt all leather she's all Bronx down
hell yeah but it was like you like ozone
from breakin one ba-ba-ba-ba so man this
girl Coco even has a baby that has
respiratory problems and so this baby
has a tank and one tank oxygen tank and
do [ __ ] to take that fool around that
she would drop him off therefore be
there what people are party dog shut it
up it's all good as book that part is
the fastest book I ever read took me a
week goddamn also that's a book I read I
read a new book this week bro
which one outliers outliers yeah it's
about convinced who lies ahead I guess
they're still writing it huh all right
reading reading that book that I jacked
from this place which I'm gonna put back
behind up here is signed by all Mexico
hey Bob died up here oh my god bro it
was coffee tables cause you would look
for heroes in that book look for Tom
dreesen he's the one that set up the
whole strike the patron saint
yes because the Comedy Store The Improv
will not paint on people a time to
perform and these were already dudes
we're making money so they're like
looking out for other comedians that
weren't yeah on the street yeah cuz I
was David Letterman Jay Leno Robert
Williams they were all supporting the
strike they wouldn't even know they were
making money it wasn't the thing where
Jay Leno crossed the picket lines and
got hit by a car
no man or guys [ __ ] it did happen
okay
he crossed the picket line he got runned
over by um by who's that the comic book
comic you know that there was sighs bro
there was a side oh sure the cuz the
all-cash or the owner i argus helmet and
you know how the old artist Hamilton
yeah but you were sleeping with her bro
there's no choice you know because
talking about the Tories in the Whigs ah
yes so he was he was on her side and so
was Charlie Hill the Native American
comedian oh wow he passed away a little
bit again man and they asked her why I
put in a paper why when he were there
protesting and Wounded Knee a Latino his
whole theory given up there real Charlie
Hill recipe brother a brave and I'm and
the other guy Joe Prater bro Ali jail
praetor yeah man that fool that the
enforcer for Missy Shore bro the leg
breaker liking people show what they
were bad who [ __ ] chase them out
George Miller was in a fight bro really
George Miller never got to return George
Miller
Elaine Boosler and some of the comments
are not as popular as Jay Leno Letterman
mm-hmm when they went up when the strike
was was off those comedian were banned
for life also she kept the shaft going
and one of the comedian's that was bad
you know not to ruin the book but he
committed suicide
oh yeah where was Annie to Hollywood
story about that stuff dude like 15
years ago and he stood committed to that
he jumped off that building that's right
next to the comedy with a comedian broke
the open air pocket bro hit a setlist
because he was an assembler though the
suicide note thinking other people to
help them Richard Lewis on the book and
say that he was so traumatized because
the guy had college which Louise and
told him that he was seeing things you
know
press and he blew it off like all you
just whatever just high whatever they
were depressed he said that full within
a 15 year drinking binge
god damn after that because of that yeah
he was but he jumped off the building
trying to land on the comments for her
store I guess he landed in the parking
lot
crazy lat but all I was it I looked up
that Titan trial when he went to prison
for that rape or whatnot it was a
February of 1992 that's when the trial
was so probably happen around ninety one
locked up around any too so yeah so that
one during the the time with that book
dude that's when the crack she was
cracking over their knees coast to the
right cracking bro because it's all that
tied into that Nino brown [ __ ] that's
when that [ __ ] was just st. Louis
[ __ ] once the corner in the back
yeah dogs for ryofu so you almost done
with the book well I'm done with the
book already know it I got a little
chilly at the end we had find out that
that guy died right cuz you know I was
expecting somebody's gonna die in this
book I don't know who was gonna die but
then when you find out who died and this
guy was author a good comic he was like
he was one of the chameleon that was
killing it at open micro and Gwynn was
village of their New York yeah before
the Emperor came along and he was
showcase at The Improv when Richard
Lewis met him so Richard Lewis in him he
took which alerts around to all the
company spots to do open mics oh and he
was a young comic yeah and what was the
deal with that deal was wrong with the
world will cut it down for why would the
press you know and a lot of bad [ __ ]
happened man like they made him in
charge of the union he wasn't ready I
guess you know it was just a lot of
factors involved a lot of facts to get
everything looking gotta read the book
and I know it got nothing to do with
them
oh [ __ ] the man is the legend and the
legend son mr. serve Russia [ __ ] your
Irish soda oh my god you don't appear
done don't be insane
mean dog who got salt sit down Oh your
EP was your life we made a really many
times - oh my god yeah man that's what
I'm shut up in and bike bro this is the
Highlander II oh yeah dog
ah [ __ ] the food I couldn't show that
was what to give a treat so we ferry the
medicine man does oh yes I was just so
forgive a care package that I kind of
attack on a [ __ ] better take also poop
our cars just got turned up man we got
our guest right here matee Moreno was we
were talking about him earlier and the
man the myth right here man
I win queer el Katrina Katrina bro
Shelley wrote a book is closed
okay here you go hell yeah man when you
could put on him I brought him in to
crash it like a crazy person
oh yeah man I don't know matter was the
last time you saw Felipe he goes [ __ ]
it's been a long time I'm doing this
podcast you want to roll he goes [ __ ]
yeah he was in Silver Lake at 9:30
tonight you worshiping to do it a long
time ago right yeah yeah never got
around busy I haven't Marty mourinho
people right here man just got off the
toilet was our fluffy he told his
one-nighters we'd ever mention him later
he's doing the one-man show thing yeah
that's unspoken word one night bro okay
bro what happens does oh my god oh well
why Thomas call it experimental comedy
welcome in experimenting for 20 years
it's not what I've done is what I'm
gonna do
I don't like baby sturgeons are going to
like the first time I watching uh
Sophia's this little page in a poncho
just looking at the whole time I got to
4 p.m. so Pancho was retired by I let my
mom go alone man here I'll even holding
my helmet okay you know what that's the
craziest [ __ ] thing like all your
guys used to say every time you see me
you'd make up this random spot all three
of you [ __ ] hey you know what
my old lady got fired from pops and
Pablo cuz I clocked her in her random
clean edges to give a short little razor
bleep in my house me bro I wake up to a
shitty time we were on the road and you
[ __ ] were on the road I would hear
that in a leap out here when I woke up
you know I hear that [ __ ] off they're
winning I was right through your fault
that was real funny he always came up
with the go under nice hey you know when
it started happening the cult of you
know and the van bro is right with a
little where's Joe Milan thank you Oh
diamond oh I'm out I do like a monkey
bar Pablo's was driving yeah hella fast
and it was foggy you couldn't see [ __ ]
my dad Ernesto anyone loaders growing
fresh coat you ran her by Meadows or
Devore one of the holes and I think I
was in and the board one had Ozzy right
Ozzy they said blaze if they were pretty
trashed come on with no ahead well I
said and so I took a hill I said I
haven't seen this dude since forecast
the woman
you called me bark at the moon for years
Ivan still has this program as part of
the moon on his phone
bark oh cool let's never take either one
aka click entry the nickname eh eh eh Oh
buddy I'm sweaty oh we're talking about
I know on the wing we're talking about
that book I'll own your dog which one or
the one you ready one week
all right so finally I'm family that way
when we're talking about the part with
that girl under settlement and a bright
nearby jackets yes
they think they want a settlement in the
net and they bite everybody leather
coats and jackets and then the next week
they were [ __ ] broke again boy these
people it's a crazy crazy [ __ ] book
yeah I read that [ __ ] in a week crazy
Coco I'm gonna tell you why yeah but
you're why I read it cause like live
Philippe it doesn't you can focus on
ship or you're just randomly behind the
mill overcomers watch and I'm like this
holy [ __ ] I go he sat you read this
whole okay that's gotta be a badass book
if it kept his attention but you're a
reader though you are a reader so yeah
but yeah I was like vodka I got inspired
us I'm gonna read this book I think I
ran like in a couple of days I was a
crazy knows who are loaded bro is [ __ ]
with boxes are all caught up in a
blanket ballgame it's getting worse for
these people never got better for them I
never that the girl Coco had a baby of
respiratory it would realize everywhere
though there was [ __ ] nuts before
getting the less difficult selling twice
before going to prison people are
getting beat down it was like like what
it was the 80s in the Bronx when it was
the crack epidemic and everybody was
selling crack around America except this
neighborhood before they order take yeah
Boy George they capitalized on heroin
because nobody was selling heroin so
this dude made a killing on [ __ ]
heroin and then there was this um this
this woman who's doing her dissertation
for her
and so she's ready books and there's
about people serving life in prison was
her story and any issue the sociologist
and and her thesis was on people serving
life in prison but then when she started
interviewing these people she realized
holy [ __ ] their stories are way more
amazing than the fact that they're
serving life and so what got them to
this point and then she backtracked on
all of their stories and they were
really fascinating actually
ha oh yeah yeah because it was all real
and it was all the 80s and [ __ ] I mean
[ __ ] you live the 80s you remember what
it was like plugging and watching
everybody hooked on [ __ ] you know on
drugs crack and everything else but but
it's not like people stopped doing
heroin they were still [ __ ] they
haven't stopped yet done up the hey damn
worser fool chilling those are what
we're gonna be at Matt everybody know
right away before the crime before they
turn off alright let's see July 7th at
magic Apple his parole at the theater in
Santa Monica on 4th Street beautiful
frickin theater and that'll be July 7th
and then the 29th I'll be at Eastside
love dude I'd love that freakin bar so
really really cool Boyle Heights that's
a behind and you can get tickets at
Eventbrite search Martine Moreno and
there are only [ __ ] ten bucks like
people are hit tell me hook me up hook
you up for the [ __ ] ten dollars like
stop we will bear you to the day you
divert me Eddie sign love I learned
every trick read what it is like every
trick April it just blade we want to
hook up before the sword blades that
means you're gonna hang out the whole
night up not yeah here with you doc so
people hook you up with one thing one
time in life and every time you come to
town and say hey remember I look up with
those tickets to look now I'm talking
like you see what happens
house down [ __ ] fine I just got you
done screaming how about my cervical and
then I got my fear
love that Jack what's the name of your a
one-man show what's going on with it you
know what it's a unn spoke I called it
unspoken word because it's not spoken
word it's not poetry what it is bro I'm
literally literally it's me speaking my
mind on how I view [ __ ] and how I got to
hear like when I was younger I thought I
knew everything I thought I did this and
now that I'm 50 I realized I don't know
[ __ ] I'm not 50 yet but I'll be 50 in a
few months and now I realize I don't
know [ __ ] and everything that I thought
I knew was [ __ ] that people told me I
should know come on bull [ __ ] oh did I
tell you bro so so basically I'm talking
about religion I'm talking about sex I'm
talking about relationships look you go
in any in most religions it's okay for a
woman to marry I mean for a guy to marry
for women
nobody blinks an eye it's [ __ ] cool
everybody's cool with it there are no
societies except in the [ __ ] like
over Nepal and sharing in the Himalayans
they are these these chicks that marry
for guys but they're brothers and it's
not like the chick picked them it's like
they'll have a ranch you know and they
don't want to give up the property so
instead of dividing it through
inheritance the brothers marry one chick
and in that way they keep it all in the
family as far as the property that it
never has to get divided but the point
is the reality is rather a woman could
probably satisfy four men emotionally
sexually and in every other [ __ ]
department way easier then a dude could
satisfy for women it's hard enough for a
[ __ ] to satisfy one woman
seriously like my girlfriend's to bring
out a toy most of the time because I'm
laying me I'm tired now and then we walk
around like guys walk around oh my god I
told I shut up last night you didn't
tear anything up nope you are not doing
any kind of damage by the time you're
done I don't care how good of a job you
did or IRA bro somebody hit ya how is
his memory
I was a 20 year old I'll enroll
torturing some damage so when I see like
guys that are like lugging like out of
shape and the 14 to 15 saying they're
doing damage shut the [ __ ] up you're not
going down so anyone I'm just like I
said I'm just going for you guys oh so
there's a live that are by putting
little wind-up haha my pussy's godmother
oh he said that bro hey bro my caliber
[ __ ] went up they were Sacramento we
went into a chick the new him with a 55
yeah bro and hey oh my god I've listened
to some of you guys with podcast no I
haven't so I can't say I've listened to
all of them but I've listened to it to a
few of them and I [ __ ] die every
single time that you [ __ ]
because you say to young dude there's so
much [ __ ] that you say that's that that
only you [ __ ] know what it is
and a handful people know but like when
you start saying plug in like the
brisket I made at mando's house I'm like
you mother of information they were
parking after their pool yeah I know
you got it right I [ __ ] had a heart
attack people this guy knows who yeah I
need me hearing this and me and water
just jumped into the podcast game like
what like four weeks ago we just jumped
in we're waiting limo video a leave my
patience I will say my listeners totally
[ __ ] on Pocket that shit's gonna go
away it started a beautician blah blah
blah and then I was like people are like
not dude it hasn't even started I'm like
shut up now bro you know hasn't even
started I know having and I'm like look
there was that sketch that Amy Schumer
did on Commodores la Rosa the man and
then she was [ __ ] like and everybody's
like hey can you do my podcast and then
I have another podcast with this other
person can you do that pot and she's
like dudes [ __ ] mayor and blew up and
that's it stop it with your [ __ ]
pocket nobody's listening nobody gives a
[ __ ] and I thought I will do more
podcasts
bro I got enough [ __ ] headaches over
here Monty Moreno there's no [ __ ]
there's no more podcast
I did there in two weeks ago he's saying
that I had a heart attack rocky he's not
doing them no one is dead
[Music]
do your one-man show talk about wicked
tears in his mouth smells like this
[ __ ] but this is dead oh my god I see
a passing around half the dollar going
on it listen listen so oh but I kill
that guy both no anyway I think it was
the first podcast that we did we were
like [ __ ] you know what Neymar was we
just sent Martina and Hooda right now
and then we keep changing the name
because every name that we try to come
up with it's taken everything that you
think like not clever you know what
working we just nice we just got here
like 10 years later and we swear nobody
thought of this [ __ ] hey nobody thought
of there's nobody thought of that and
then I go there's this podcasters of
that pot gotta go
there's a [ __ ] yeah man podcast and
it's not even but yeah mannered good
familiar man I've you know I told them I
told them that you had a podcast that
said yeah man and he's like what oh yeah
cuz you know what it's a catchphrase
no let's listen every comic strives to
get a catchphrase like don't worry
yourself as Nobles at night Lopez was
like member when when he said remember
remember dude everybody and their mother
was saying memory you know you've got
catch with what's up fool that's catchy
and so when you've got something that
everybody and their mother is repeating
like yeah man why would you get mad that
they're repeating it instead of
embracing I just get mad when I'm in San
Antonio would I hope people remember to
Maryland is what you should embrace and
say [ __ ] it this is like like okay for
instance pretty cool if people would
tell if I would say you know what I find
it but I mean I would cost me I want it
out of it but it's not what I say it's
what I do
what will really Sparkle morning is when
you get heated in arguments cool right
what's special with that fool like that
yeah trying to like break you down yeah
yeah then this whole trying to say right
here I can put I did a I did lots
Provencher to a broad you right there
next to the do vibe board bro
hey you guys making references about so
many things about my ferocious
boxing ferocious little he looks like a
donkey bro hey bro
Oh it'll get you in a wrestling move but
you have to let him put you in the dog
alright everybody you got that rest of
the [ __ ] motels a row I didn't do
[ __ ] our house in my son he got that
wrestler to [ __ ] them up bro please just
you know yeah look if you guys never
mention names alright whatever kids but
okay now ready bar sorry hold on you go
first oh my god oh dude I brought you
too soon I even bother here's a stay
here's the worst when you're like us
when you're starting off as a common
hungry you're hungry you'll do anything
and so all these you've added to sushi
with very many nice
absolutely whoever takes you out on the
road you're like [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
I'm gonna go and you're excited
especially if it's somebody that's got a
boatload of credits and [ __ ] and you're
like this is [ __ ] awesome and then
you get out there and then and then you
might have ten minutes on the material
like and then they're like oh you're
gonna do twenty because it's just me and
you see like oh [ __ ] I got to stretch my
ten right this is what happens mister
took me out that I might have been in
maybe about a year I might have had
maybe ten minutes that were [ __ ]
funny and they were happiest [ __ ] like
when I look back at the early [ __ ] and
and you know what you won't think you're
in his defense and hopefully over those
English effects heat no no he gave me
some of the best advice that I never
took he did give me good advice because
early on somebody came to me and said
we're gonna record this DVD
it's called comedy Fiesta or something
like that and maybe I was probably about
maybe a year and a half two years and I
swore I was killing to those two Laugh
Factory Latino night and they would
laugh and give me a price break I
thought I was ready for [ __ ] primetime
and then when I said hey dude these
dudes [ __ ] offered me this spot where
I'm gonna get on the DVD and I'm up to
20 minutes and he's like don't do it you
know that's crazy your materials not
ready to go out on blast like that and I
was like in my hand like this [ __ ]
hater man like I saw your screen
later there was really solid advice that
he gave me to know the Chuck Norris baby
hey by you I wait till they hear this
[ __ ] is genius it's kind of hell you
know they don't know about I want my
baby back
oh I swore I saw Clara okay so so what
take care of it good job Oh Poochie
mommy's my my I'm sorry I can't breathe
so what listen so he takes me out on the
[ __ ] Road I'm excited I do my teton
by 20 minutes I pulled it out of my ass
it was a light crowd it was a Thursday
and then this is what he said to me hey
man you know can I talk to you is that
really good substage that's right bottom
of people's can I talk to you I goes all
that stuff that you do about marriage
and about this and about that like
basically every [ __ ] joke that I do
is that I do that so just difficult
please don't do any of that material so
now the next day I gotta go to 20
minutes I got I stretched what the pen
that sucked and I got nothing right so
now I'm like so where do you live yeah
hey so what are you working on the
roughest I'll do when I strike off I
pull off 20 minutes and it's like
pulling teeth but I pull off 20 [ __ ]
minutes and then this is what he [ __ ]
says to me I'm thinking to myself he's
got to be happy now
oh but I like that abused wife just
trying to please this [ __ ] right
like now he's gonna love me now he's
gonna accept me and then they're like so
how is that good hey you know what
listen you're only doing 20 bro like
don't talk to the crowd just do material
cuz cuz when you talk to the crowd and
then I do I gotta be up there for an
hour bro so when you talk to them and
then I got a talk it kind of takes away
from what I'm doing so if you could just
not do that hey bro just have fun the
material and I'm like the [ __ ] am I
gonna do
the second time I went faster dog the
sexy I right twist balloons dog
[Laughter]
where's the Latinos at so like when I
went back a year later I think I went up
with Gabriel on you and this was [ __ ]
girls obviously part like holy [ __ ]
Marty's variety - it was [ __ ] funny
man that was a weak man it was a crazy
weekend out partying back weak man and
weird party with one of the waiters and
that foot he was just me read you got
one of my script or my poem is [ __ ] he
said we're getting a poem and he lookin
at ya wanna bump now oh hey dude those
[ __ ] pumps listen I experiment with
pumps and why are you on the phone
without giving this one buys with a
bubble showed up become party bro to
l'amour no my god there's [ __ ] three
hours earlier in our labor forgiveness
on a vibe don't be coy I'll be home
look at how God replies though when I'm
high I had the [ __ ] bested by cuz
you're round you know you get carrying
it out how they're going on us funny
though like I say to myself people say
picked over to Coco I did it in the 80s
you know and then like in the
not-so-well high school Andrew well yeah
well [ __ ] it was all over the place bro
I mean cuz high school people you in a
big band yes louder oh [ __ ] [ __ ] your
stoner here are your whole life my whole
life yeah I was I had I had way huge
hair in high school and all my friends
were like like like we were like the
guys out listening to Slayer and
Metallica and everybody else was
listening to Motley Crue and Duran Duran
and I saw I don't see a [ __ ] yeah well
yeah exactly and we're like and so
everybody like that we knew played
instruments and they were in bands and
ship were broke as kids from the hood we
couldn't afford it we can we call my mom
go to Guitar Center and buy me a buy me
a [ __ ] now Oh what happened
they closed the market closer to the
night alright [ __ ] it
alright act decent [ __ ] that what the
[ __ ] was I talking about the don't
belong here oh yeah solo we want it we
want to
like dude everybody wanted to be in a
band everybody start like we're gonna
start a band and I was gonna play bass
my friend Alex was gonna play drums
Mario was gonna support Joker don't was
gonna do that much he was gonna do one
guitar and then and then my other homie
Pete was going to be a Bisson we told
people we had a bad name we were
slaughtered before the real slaughter
like seriously there was no slaughter
before us we had a lot of it we had a
jacket with a skull on the top it's at
slaughter with like metal letters and
then I wrote this like cryptic ass
[ __ ] lyric I could let this go shell
rise the curtain will reveal that in
this [ __ ] world only memory right
yeah prove it
Oh dog brawls [ __ ] writing songs we
uh we had everything on instruments we
had songs we had lyrics we had our work
we had we had a name we had groupies
dude we saw us party every like hey
Gracie was there oh my god I'm even
throwing away chicks and this was all
bring me one dollar work sorry oh my god
no we weren't we were dude we literally
had [ __ ] six following us around we
were out we were at the waters in San
Pedro one time and this band savage
grace was playing and I don't know one
of our one of my friends went up there
and said hey can you say dedicate a song
to the guys from slaughter than the IRA
[ __ ] fans said oh this goes out to
our friends slaughter they're here
tonight and the people like who the [ __ ]
is slaughter and they're looking around
in the dark
yeah dude and dude we'd walk into
parties into there like those are the
guys from slaughter and then so then
there always be a band playing in the
backyard you know and you guys want to
jam with us nah bro we only play
together because that's how it'll break
up you know where's my man where
everything for so many years but we'll
play with my face it doesn't sound the
same and just kind of compromises the
art bro 33 me get my cheese room oh dude
it looks really good [ __ ] for his
lottery lottery we were slaughter before
slaughter I sort of God there was no and
my friend Alex used to do pen pal [ __ ]
with like metalheads from like around
the world and he told this dude from
wherever slaughter came for
that he had a bad name smarter and lo
and behold a few years later slaughter
was formed I'm not saying that they
stole our name but it was a [ __ ]
crazy ask away that is a slaughter over
there in San Pedro Mike we must
slaughter them I look Hardy like in high
school I did bro I love house party I
crazy I did you know what I did I did I
did like a lot of metal parties and like
like backyard parties I remember I did
crap I smoked crack in high school I
didn't know it was crack like I used to
smoke weed and then I remember one time
my friend said hey we're gonna go
freebase and I go freebase what is that
he goes bro
you'll love it bro dude it's badasses
did you just gotta go just gotta get
your hair out of the way cuz you don't
want it to catch on fire cuz but I it
was a production back then that's a
big-ass pipe it's it's kind of like
dabbing today bro when I see people
dabbing I'm like [ __ ] that looks like a
crack apparatus you know it doesn't stop
me from trying it but holy [ __ ] it is
scary and so [ __ ] they had this big
thing and then they had cotton balls and
then they torched it and then I remember
they said okay hold your hair back and
then you're gonna get on the pipe and
then just inhale slowly and I'm like
every [ __ ] endorphin my body ever
created fired off that [ __ ] felt [ __ ]
amazing it was like what the [ __ ] and
I'm like what is this no it's freebase I
went home and I told my neighbor I go
bro
you gotta try freebase and he goes what
is it I go to this new drug and it goes
is it weed I go no no it's not wait a
sec coke now it's not coke he goes what
is I could freebase I'm like yelling at
him because he didn't know what freebase
was but it was before they called it
crack they call it freebasing and [ __ ]
did you pray heaven powder they rocked
it up although they were rocked up when
I got there by the time I got there they
were already rocked up but then I
remember seeing people cook that [ __ ] up
afterwards and that's not what the guys
that were slanging it but yeah it was
[ __ ] everywhere bro and you know
what's crazy like when you try coke it
the first time I tried coke I was
probably 15 maybe 16 damn 15 or 16 in
Wilmington
a little bumpy well we were at this
[ __ ] pad this chick was dating a drug
dealer and my friend was dating her
younger sister but we all look older we
all looked way later we were all we all
we all had long hair and [ __ ] and
they're like we're gonna go to this pad
and their party and we get there just
got a [ __ ] machine gun by the door
those guns everywhere they got
table photo rolling on a table for coral
Collies [ __ ] dog this is [ __ ]
Wilma's in the eighties they're only for
slaughter
ha ha hey for you so the catering and
I'm chilling I'd never tried this [ __ ]
in my life and then they [ __ ] put a
line right there and I [ __ ] when it's
had to have been the [ __ ] that was
coming from Escobar if it was [ __ ]
but the the mid-80s there's no way and
[ __ ] it was anything build a good house
it was amazing it was [ __ ] amazing
and then after that you know it would
come around every once in a while I
would try it
I've experimented with coke in the 80s
in the 90s and in the 2000 all over the
continent was a you know it's [ __ ]
crazy oh the laverre city bro to do coke
for me in Los Angeles because it was
early and it was the good [ __ ] the
weirdest experience was um about a year
and a half ago and I don't know
felicitate using I know you would think
I was I thought I'm not a coke head but
every time I know it would listen Redman
this my slaughtered role yes so this is
like this is for the next day after I
did it we got a 10 o'clock show right I
was with Gabe over at the [ __ ] Mirage
and and Ryan is in the back is the the
road manager guy and my throat was all
[ __ ] up right and then he goes dude
because you were office there is no cake
oh man my throat's [ __ ] with me man
he's like what's wrong you're getting
sick I got man I don't know I think I
did coke last night and he goes you
think you did call to go no I did and he
goes he goes
so here's every more senior [ __ ]
voice I do you like first you like I
think and I know I did he goes who did
you do coke with I go some [ __ ] gay
guy in the bathroom and he's like what
the [ __ ] but what happened was after the
show having a few drinks just chilling
were you there Ivan yeah so we're
chilling and I'm just having I'm I
started drinking the wine and I said why
I know water go top bubble oh and you
know Jake's astounding me cuz he came to
Vegas Boca I offered him what this
[ __ ] had cirrhosis for the last
20 years he won't die bro he did
experimental [ __ ] medication from
Germany Lady botting Guadalajara bro
this little [ __ ] still are you still
drinking you showed up to visit me
we ran out of beer and I go I got some
wine Eagles wine I'm trying out wine and
so then I I get to Waianae poor and he
slips it around he goes the [ __ ] would
your dad think okay like talking to me
bro him to get more [ __ ] beer but Oh
anyway the [ __ ] gay guy so it's now
it's Vegas it's 5:00 in the morning
nobody's cut me off I'm still [ __ ]
pounding I'm annihilator but I'm [ __ ]
an island you know when you're goated
and nobody should give you any more
alcohol that's what I was but I'm still
[ __ ] pounding in this gay guy and
this chick that he's with who I swore I
was gonna hook up with I I scoped he
said Carrie were telling me cold alcohol
okay yeah bro no but they were
house-elves
is just the alcohol and this
[ __ ] goes hey get us some posse
which means do you want a bump and I was
like all right and so they're like he
goes let's go so we'll go to the
bathroom right and I walked into one of
the stalls it was noventa Becca come
over here and it goes into the
handicapped bathroom no room
what's up and more room in there yeah 66
so he sits on the toilet he brings up
this little bag and listen I hadn't done
coke in years so I'm like I don't want
to go crazy like because now I'll [ __ ]
it all but I don't want to die you know
like you just think to yourself if I try
this [ __ ] this is going to be the one
that takes me out and then I'll be that
guy that bike from cocaine even though
I'm not a cocaine right and so so I'm
like let me do a little bump right so I
do a little bump and then he goes back
from the mines the more and I'm like all
right
oh yes generous right so now I'm [ __ ]
going you get one in until I have
[ __ ] it opens up the passageways
looking and you get this little going
right go ahead with a little bit of
water so I'll sleep I mouth deep in
there and then this one Oh [ __ ] looks
up and it goes get us on the Halal oh
wow yeah it is two on a [ __ ] Pokiri
and I'm looking and I just the thing in
my nose and I'm like I'm looking down
and I'm like just a devil I'm good no
soy bean blushes I said listen and who
knows if I would have been really horny
I might have taken it but I was still
thinking I had a chance with the chick I
don't want to cock-block myself by
hooking up with the chubby gay guy
alright he was children to enjoy several
and he spoke only Spanish manuals we're
like teachers what about
he was one of those he was one of those
dudes that like wears like the Louis
Vuitton shoes and with the Gucci shoes
out of design he and all the designers
really nice a karaoke diva so some guy
to do karaoke every night with the
comments on fat ass by the microphone
well [ __ ] diva laughs oh my god that
you might Fiero dog where's that flat a
low-priority cleghorne brother rooster
now they're doing a documentary on
tortillas where are they now and I think
he's in it okay Deba to the tooth you
know who iced I saw I saw the dude Oscar
and that other guy Jose as I'm gonna
blew in New York or something I don't
know well this is a few years ago but
they were at a restaurant in Long Beach
next to the yard house it's like some
tequila restaurant a few of the number
that the bartender Randy I think was his
name yeah he's working there he owes it
then the owner walk the reason probably
I don't know but it's a tequila bar in
Long Beach over there by by the yard
house yeah a bunch of the crew from the
theater wile coyote what of the hell was
that
well Cory Raza we're doing is missing
hair though nice so you don't shave that
Muslim or Jew hey bro mango shaves what
other shaved clothing could your skin's
never look better that's all the shape
for doing a star bro I'm trying to get
this tattoo moon
yeah shark of Dollar Shave Club
contingency funds to the what so full
podcast and they want to remind you that
Father's Day is right around the corner
right bro mo while they run a car under
a dick in it that can help keep dad
looking his best without paying an arm
and a leg with the smoothest shave
around thanks to their high-quality
blades and amazing
dr. Carver shake love how that doctor
shall recover stay gloves it's [ __ ]
phenomenal bro you know I'm saying it's
good I like it dude [ __ ] dude no no
nothing just like blue carbon shea
butter I totally do that's the mood well
you're gonna die like a baby's at what
oh yeah when new members can get their
first most off the executive razor with
a tube of the shea butter for only $5
why with free shipping and after that it
costs you just a few [ __ ] boys a
month man and that's not all just an
offer a Dollar Shave Club dot-com /foo
somebody knows something you want to
shave man you're in a [ __ ] big hurry
the [ __ ] manager do they have the
[ __ ] keys to the razors row that's
unlock oh that's - [ __ ] [ __ ]
they sling razor Billy razors and in my
life there's a lot of the metabolizes
people were stealing it oh do you know
what I like what I remember I used to
predict yeah boy know that we reproduce
it Similac I remember I check out hooked
up with in Visalia and she send me a
text bro we hooked up one time this
chick is after a show on a pretty much
no I'm sorry
and so [ __ ] it this chuckles hardly this
is embarrassing I know I just met you
but can you help me out and send me some
money cuz I want to get some more before
my put my baby in all I remember is life
yeah and you kept a today have you seen
your symbol like chicks but do you love
jinx bro oh he was good guy brother he
was satisfied not not one she hating him
just his first girlfriend bro coffee
calls me up New Year's Eve bro hahaha to
kill somebody I'm Johnny the [ __ ]
snow dog this game was [ __ ] whatever
the [ __ ] rain throw like [ __ ]
plane train automobile broke
did I forget an old one I got a flight
and we got in a [ __ ] big ass fight
we'd find out we did we dated for ten
years and we get in fights every other
month we break up we could make one
together yeah don't say her name glad
you know but but uh but anyway [ __ ]
we get in fights oh we're in [ __ ] a
Tahoe bro we went to Tahoe right crashed
will we show will he had a show out
there so he gave me a guest spot we go
on there and then we're drinking we're
drinking and then
starts fighting over some bullsh and
then I can't put up a [ __ ] I'm like
no you're [ __ ] full of [ __ ] if you're
full of [ __ ] I'll tell you you're full
of [ __ ] you know it's like when people
like say oh you got to respect
somebody's beliefs go [ __ ] yourself like
if your belief if you're telling me hey
what's your Santa Claus look this look
like I'm omec [ __ ] you're a
grown human
I can't just you know I just [ __ ]
kill ya which loves and I put the legal
[ __ ]
stop with the stop pretending that this
is like the this is real like this is
fake and I can't like stole the Lupus
yeah so so we get this big-ass giant
fight and then I'm like you know what
[ __ ] it let's go bro I'm [ __ ] loaded
it's snowing we're driving down the hill
we're heading through Oakland bro
and I had no money I got no money I got
the check
epic gave me from the [ __ ] gig and
I'm like so we go to flag in Oakland
she's got though she books us and we got
we're nah I think we're on a rental we
turned in the [ __ ] car and shoot
she's like are you sure you know [ __ ]
that I'm good at the flight was the next
day bro and I'm like I'll just kick here
at the airport I'll go [ __ ] I was out
there or drunk
and then once I sobered up a few hours
later I'm like [ __ ] I was hungry
I was over a good Ally thirsty and then
you know what I said I can't believe
this [ __ ] left me here like that's a
[ __ ] thing I say like oh I'm the one
- yeah I like - but I was that girl to
drop me off swearing they weren't gonna
drop me off and then and then mad when
they didn't circle or up to get me like
I was that crazy [ __ ] right so now that
the airport where I'm at the airport I
think I called Joker Joker bought me a
plane ticket and uh and I got home out
of pay him later
oh my god luckily your best friend you
know what I haven't talked to Joker in a
long time but but we are was that doodle
with you with yeah we're you know that
drug dealer he'll study here scary
people colors bro good words
Rosarito and I was a bike ride oh you
tell me you miss your girlfriend at the
bike ride you fell off yes when I was a
different bike ride well I used to do a
lot of bike rides but yeah I fell off
the bus another two or the reader or
listener TJ's emotionally torn off from
Rosarito ruin scenarios or the bike ride
and so we'd rent a house and a bunch of
people would go all the people that
would ride you know
as all the people I used to work when I
was working at UCLA all these people
would go to this one week stay there and
this one dude was all sucked out and and
it's late everybody's passed out except
for me that fool and Joker right and it
goes you know like when you kill
somebody and and you just just look at
them
it rests where you lay Holmes and I you
know I don't wanna [ __ ] I'm loaded
right so I want to keep up with the
Joneses right so I looked there we go
I never stick around that long bro start
pulling trigger I'm gone [ __ ] it
and joko pipes up how many people have
you killed and I'm like shut the [ __ ] up
go back you [ __ ] up my failure I
bladder on me a little more amore oh my
god bro yeah let's do that
I would be much the man we were what
time we're partying um I don't know what
happened but we ended up where people
are fool I was a [ __ ] Phoenix doing
the tip oh and so learn from that nice
shoulder also which I'm from the [ __ ]
yeah when we were a little oil
yeah hot plug yeah we're oh I saw you
and we party bro but I remember people i
party with now bro we partied nahban
poison a long time nah man you and I do
my thinking to our house and I'm [ __ ]
awesome bro but one of the best time I
ever had I thought both would have been
the horrible night for me then the
problems do you remember that night
Tigers bro I remember waking up with you
eating my noodle bro oh my god well I I
was so mad I was so mad at you bro whit
listen listen
I had a [ __ ] suite at the Crowne
Plaza ball and know this we'll have one
we're sharing the suite was his suite
this little [ __ ] out of suite and then
he said you know it was a what the [ __ ]
was the name of that comedy club
Wreckers no rascals rascals and rascals
it was me you Rudy Gabriel and I forget
who else I think Ivan might have been
there you weren't there
mondo mondo mondo was there and Annan
and then you're like aid there's a bunch
of people coming to my room we're gonna
party I'm like well [ __ ] it let's go
there's a pop maybe 25 30 people in this
[ __ ] room and we're [ __ ] sweat a
mountain bro okay for smoking weed
there's a bunch of wheat and you could
smell it it's like a [ __ ] ton of Bud
right like
a boatload of weed like everybody was
really well and everybody like to
everybody smoking blunts and [ __ ] all of
a sudden there's a knock at the [ __ ]
door and everybody runs to the bathroom
oh yeah I nobody's gonna know so here's
a coke [ __ ] the door opened and
it was like a crowd like like like
remember when Spicoli gets dropped off
at this time at ridgemont high and now
like a cloud of smoke came out and and
uh I remember Gabe said 8:00 they said
if you don't leave they're gonna call
the cops
and they're gonna arrest you and we
thought he was [ __ ] [ __ ] with you
yeah and he's like no I'm not [ __ ]
with you and then he goes here's some
money
you guys are gonna need a hotel but you
have to go cuz you're gonna go to jail
and I'm like what the [ __ ] but but but
you gotta understand we were loaded so
when you're up in dealer you're like eh
[ __ ] it let's go away and that because
we will go to my pad and we're like [ __ ]
it we jumped in cars bro and we go
[ __ ] let me tell you something there's
a pallet burning in front of houses
right other the other side of the tracks
listen I go I go where the [ __ ] our way
and politicals who we all recognize the
projects and I quote [ __ ] sorry
it was a Friday little project so the
projects and [ __ ] Phoenix we end up
at this and inside this pad this chick
is [ __ ] got kids there and and
they're cutting up coke and she's
telling me how she left LA so she could
get her life together and how I want to
[ __ ] is this together how bad was it
right and so it got weird this gave the
dude a Viagra
he came oh by agra and i'm like thinking
holy [ __ ] cuz i'm like in my head I'm
like this guy's hearts can explode bro
you got [ __ ] weed yellow chakra and
we were - we're doing lines all night
all [ __ ] night at like maybe 5:00 in
the morning or maybe like 4:30 or 5:00
in the morning well like we got we
should leave and we try to call a cab
right and no cab would come finally a
cab showed up in this [ __ ] and in the
back of the cab and I go no money things
yeah no meter right me and it goes and
for difficult a you don't have a meter
and it goes and meter sonic got away the
meter is going to be expensive you want
to write or what
yeah let's go so we get in this dude's
car and I go a man who's selling alcohol
right now he goes Legere well after
hours so it takes us to this block
that's a drive-through bros before 6:00
and we bought it we bought more beer
this is how [ __ ] late we were we
bought more beer and this guy's taking
us to find a hotel we went we must've
went to about 20 [ __ ] hotels they're
all sold out from this floor about to be
homeless well and this guy's like Iran
I'm gonna take you guys over to Apache
[ __ ] Apache Junction yeah Indian
School Road Indian School Road it was a
hotel six with a racquetball court you
know what it looked like it looked like
remember those yellow parliaments I used
to look at live at and Wilmington it was
a golf course yeah with the golf course
and look like that it looked like an
apartment building but it's a motel 6
with like people living there bro and
and so because if there's nothing here
I'm just gonna take you guys to my house
and you could sleep in the car he felt
sorry already God he felt sorry for us
but he didn't even charge us like dude
this dude drove us for hours bro looking
for something we it was daylight by the
time we found the [ __ ] hotel we
blacked out the room we passed out I
woke up this fool was gone I was like
where the [ __ ] this [ __ ] go
right and I'm mad I'm [ __ ] mad I'm
outside there's crackheads out there who
look pretty no somebody yes there was a
pimp beating up and slugging chick dude
listen the stood looking at me and in
the [ __ ] distance I can see the
Crowne Plaza alright and this crisis
crack kids are looking at me I go you
know last night and my shirts all
stained can I go
last night I had a suite up there and
they're looking at me like y'all right
[ __ ] like I look like that guy
look like the homeless guy telling
people I'm a doctor in India or some
[ __ ] like that right and then this fool
came back and he goes and I was mad bro
he goes hey I brought you my noodle bro
hella [ __ ] you [ __ ] man you know I
thought my noodle like a happy dude that
[ __ ] was crazy I remember you made a bit
out of it because that night you talked
about ever and you what did you say you
said a self up with the maid stole the
[ __ ] towels of a sort our bro then
come your head over oh I'll get a
sketball cord
oh this was the line that you said you
said listen when you're partying at the
at the krump
Wazza with your friends in a suite
you're partying you're having a good
time when you're partying at the motel 6
an Indian School Road you're not
partying
you're drug addict get some help
laughing going right I showed up what
time breath bag dude it was crazy
brother or what doesn't know where I
came from I was disappointed riving
around looking for somewhere to stay
then I remember all just one is in
Montebello oh my god I should have like
a walking dead dog with the blind guy
[Laughter]
Garfield
yeah yes love with Anthony Anthony left
bro the I woke up it was Valentine's Day
and I had just gotten back with that
chick I was telling nobody was a Beatle
we're about to go to Rosarito for
Valentine's Day right and I learned
others talk to me I look I look out my
window I look out my window and this
[ __ ] out there born what the
[ __ ] is he doing up and there's a big
case of [ __ ] queer enough ice bro a
[ __ ] empty case of Smirnoff fun and
then I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing here girl
we had nowhere to go away I go and it
was there and you were in OD bro you
were [ __ ] loaded and I go Brahma bull
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] blah blah blah blahs
coming but we're going we're going on a
date he goes take me with you echo like
I'm just getting back with her bro this
is my makeup day this Valentine's Day he
goes I'll land the backseat and be quiet
okay nothing keeping a food trend micro
I can't bro we'll drop you off where we
don't drop me off vehicle we'll take you
home but whatever for tonight I saw
another chick shows up I go listen I'll
have to take a little bit to her okay
a bit a detour 35 minutes that we you
know what I remember the most with her
when I said I was brainstorming where a
[ __ ] car
we're in a car right when a car riding
to San Francisco and hits me Felipe
mondo
I hit
Gabriel right and and and and this chick
calls me because we had just moved in
together she had a key to my place I
don't know I was stupid bro I was stupid
I I have this that I wrote I try to
remember every girl that I've ever been
with
oh look right I started writing the
names and then oh oh my gosh make sure
the names
I put big-ass kid very spoke alright bro
bro this was all so she so she found the
[ __ ] this bro
yes you [ __ ] calls me and I'm like oh
[ __ ] you got understand bro like my
car was in every book dog park
everything was in her name like if there
wasn't for this check I would have been
standing here today I see [ __ ] was on
solid was she's number one of these hard
to ha I think it was alphabetical okay
now listen
it was stupid bro and so I'm like making
all these excuses and I'm like I'm
looking at my relationship and
everybody's quiet in the car right and I
go yeah I was writing material I was I
was brainstorming in unison the whole
[ __ ] car goes I would praise for me
laugh every single one of those little
[ __ ] said that [ __ ] well I go hey I
gotta go call you back I'm like you guys
stop [ __ ] rocked and I was so sad bro
how would you be can is your border I
don't know what I was doing Brown stupid
Alexi houses who for this would Amin
what did you write about her crazy good
weren't just [ __ ] my house cuz she
was in the bushes one day leave Dawg she
wouldn't leave no I couldn't leave no
yeah I woulda let her walk out over the
door bro are you serious I don't see
nobody online as soon as I open the term
pop stop well like what the [ __ ] I
called like I pretend that I was calling
the cops
let's do dis it was [ __ ] insane bro
but y'all there you are but you know
what it's that we hear what that stems
from is cheating and lying dude when you
make somebody like like I would blame
her I'd be like she's a [ __ ] psycho
[ __ ] but the reality is that how was
the [ __ ] because I'd be like I
[ __ ] love you
one and only or all I need and then I'd
be out there [ __ ] around bro bro I
oh my god this say one time poor thing
she's gonna hear [ __ ] if we're not we
haven't been together in years so she uh
she cook off to Europe and that's right
and she left me her car and I and I had
this chick from I had frequent flyer
miles from Southwest so I had a free
trip but I had met this [ __ ] chick
and Houston Houston I wanna hook up with
saw her hair that she came in her hair
ended up on the bed right and she goes
what's this hair and that's when I had a
[ __ ] fade bro and I know well Felipe
[ __ ] got loaded and he passed out she
goes oh it's kind of straight it doesn't
look like what people know I lived over
here so a week later bro she showed up
to pick me up and she had had her car
washed and detailed and I'm the
passenger seat on the dashboard was a
long piece of hair because I check had
been in the car
but everything fits the armor all days
right so like armor all in the dash
right then right and there's a piece I
hear just perfectly placed in front of
my seat right and I'm chilling and
they're like what the [ __ ] oh yeah right
and she knows it's there actually knows
who this chick did this chick would
torture me bro
remind me to tell you what I'm Georgia
her like what time she called when I
would really listen what are the what
are the odds
well listen I threw that here I like
that hair stayed there for a week every
time she leave me on her she left no
wait wait let it okay listen listen
listen listen because I can't say what
the [ __ ] is this hair she's like oh so
say one that wasn't so deep in the car
too as soon as they look at so listen
some like I'm there she picked me up
like three times the [ __ ] hair still
there bro like I'm like you know what I
don't know a little Buddha bottle broke
I hope it I opened the ID open the
window I start blowing I'll try to get
this [ __ ] to get out right cuz I know
she just can't wait to call me on the
[ __ ] hair right and then finally I
couldn't take it no more bro I we
stopped at a red light and she turned to
the left and I remember I had the window
open I grabbed the hair and I throw it
out the window and I just chilled cuz
now I know if she says something I'm not
gonna what are you talking about I know
you're a crazy person right so but I
remember when she looked
/ and she saw that it was gone the look
on her face like what the [ __ ] happened
in my hair and I was like I remember I
text Gabe or I take someone and I was
like I just got rid of the [ __ ] hair
like I was like so happy or like a this
chick was a detective bro but everything
everything would line up against me
roses loose listen then time I was in
Fullerton there was coke doses one night
those a [ __ ] room out there and those
this chick I met in the parking lot
nobody that I would hook up with but I
didn't want to drive because I don't
want to get vui she was we want to go to
my house I live around the corner I go
[ __ ] yeah let's go
she had candles she had booze she goes
you could just crash here and my phone
kept ringing and my girlfriend kept
blowing me up right and I'm like [ __ ] I
send it to voicemail send it to
voicemail send it to voicemail I go to
the bathroom to take a piss she called
this [ __ ] picked up no no it gets
better they know each other what are the
chances that they [ __ ] knew each
other they stalked right and I'm just
sitting there and I didn't do [ __ ] with
this chick I didn't do anything with
this girl we just hung out right
the next day she showed up to my house
and we got the lunch she paid for lunch
and then she said you know I had a dream
like all you had a dream and she goes
yeah and she starts telling me
everything that happened and you're with
this girl in those candles and she
starts describing her house and I'm like
like now I know that Ramona issues like
I can polish she knows and I'm like no
I'm mad right I go why not [ __ ] you
tell me like oh my wait [ __ ] you gotta
drag it out and buy me lunch and make me
feel like an [ __ ] right world's it
gets me our terms are conspiring yeah
did I treat it you know what
like in retrospect like I said I was the
[ __ ] I also [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know
what [ __ ] threat respect is not a big
word you [ __ ] no but I need you to just
obey me ooh hello buy a [ __ ] dildo
bro
can you use it every chick and you put a
condom on it right so we could be
cleaner I know Club it put a condom on
and the under vibrate and the dildo
listener himself broke it's like a
vibrator screaming who told me bro
you're a [ __ ] Jew boy you see it was
all loaded bro everywhere I was I told a
devil that story right I got scared bro
hey I'm a doc no I told him bro job bro
so tell the alternate all example a
story that this would totally go with my
story right Sarika master stateroom
Marty cerebral here telling back now bro
my team stared off with your hand
problem row next time bro your problems
you gonna stick your finger up that
growth as dawg
and then when she looks you like what
the [ __ ] happened you [ __ ] slapper
burr on a bass rope and I told him that
would matter I put a pilot I can't do
that dawg
listen in fashion you could die listen
listen in passion any like consent is
[ __ ] huge that's a big thing right
now like consent and I think that as
guys especially like older guys we grew
up in a time which is no excuse for it
but we grew up in a time where women
weren't supposed to like sex and when
when you should marry that's it not yeah
those do a girl's job was just to please
the guy and and you do it after marriage
and you're not supposed to enjoy it it's
the guy always wants it even see shows
today where the guy's the one oh come on
honey give me some [ __ ] [ __ ] and no
jiggle not right now like but let's big
address yeah exactly take out the trash
and I'll give you [ __ ] and so back then
girls were supposed to act like did it
like it and that whole like that's where
know that that's where no means no got
really blurred because a lot of times
they be like no as they're grinding into
you and and and again consent should be
[ __ ] set like I wanna [ __ ] you
shouldn't have to I tell people this all
time if you have to talk somebody into
something you're a piece of [ __ ] this
one guy told me this day I'm almost got
her talked into a threesome I'm like
your dick
we talked into it and he goes well yeah
you know and I go if you want to have a
[ __ ] threesome before you get
together with this person say hey I like
the [ __ ] groups I like to [ __ ] two
people at the same time if you're
much down order but listen if you're not
down then we shouldn't date yeah you
know you should use and then he goes Wow
and then you could get away with it
later go you're not getting away with
[ __ ] you [ __ ] ass [ __ ] you're just
you're just you just being honest with
what you want but I think it's harder to
do when you're young when you're young
it's hard to say what you want and you
just kind of try to like connive your
way into it instead of I tell you wanted
to say I really I would have rigged a
bra bro did you really fit this locate
my chick said she was walking to the
bathroom kind of funny it was about her
that dude gave her from San Francisco it
was like I have someone else Viagra and
Cialis not as I Alice knows levitra
levitra no I think I know what others I
think you know I was that dude they were
hanging out where they gave us the
viagra and pills in [ __ ] San
Francisco remember trying to leave him
and go now brother never I was gonna buy
a puppy tomorrow
Briona zoo bro oh my god can you shake
this guy off yeah no I'll eat it while
voting bro I have a play brother step
okay stop some Fresno because I got a
zoo we should get kidnapped by people
don't oh my god that's [ __ ] funny I
got a dude bag ah you know what I was
thinking about member and I'll pass home
this is the store girl Robbie rest in
peace you know she passed away right no
she passed away she had like a botched
uh she went to Juarez for a really for a
limitation or something no for a like
liposuction and it went wrong and she
passed away she was a big girl she was a
really big girl remember we were like
the number of button thought around
black comedy three comedy no he's like a
he's a he works as a stagehand or some
yeah but I remember we had a poker party
we're hanging out and I
I got liberal I have taken a Viagra and
I another chick doe supposed to show up
to the club never showed up
mother fortune teller
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh you always jump into
things oh no you wanna go a week we just
do your [ __ ] wine all weekend that's
today that's here no more beers cheese
and then after no more clothes it's no
fireman
Oh mouthing I'm in T that's [ __ ] fine
then just [ __ ] though the [ __ ]
other those were those Indian cigarettes
cook just clothes a nice well but this
[ __ ] guy [ __ ] Ivan like because I
I hooked up with her one time it allows
me April and I hooked up with her winter
pad and I remember like any time I don't
see a chick he'd be like damn I would
tear that [ __ ] up like oh you would I go
I don't know that I could hook up with
that he was all pit or ah BC sale I said
all the time
what's the PC over she's done bonus he
saw dude the first time I went to a Paso
it was with Felipe gay bro Ivan I forgot
also mando and I brought that with us
when we took we [ __ ] put leg we took
the grocery cart to the condo yeah
we saw with you know what you guys there
over there I think you made me and Ben
here I think so anyways check those out
Rick that showed up to the show and then
these guys went to the casino and she
came to the condo and she goes to this
was you know what this was still like
gay locals ya got me made bro like like
I said you got it like that I got a I
got a picture of her I got this dis dis
this [ __ ] like my logic
I got a collage of pictures and she made
it to the [ __ ] collage because this
is crying nothing anymore I
shechem armonica [ __ ] give me my
art project we'll make a stencil does
that chick used to hang out by the
speaker and you suck off your chairs yes
your DJ chick is you just devil to speak
liberal she and she'd wait no her body
nice cute we salute I used to do a show
over at a hop in Lakewood and she'd
always wait for me there and I was date
and this was when I was with that chick
and we got in a fight that day now say
you know what [ __ ] it today I'm hooking
up with this chick so I go straight
there I wasn't even booked but I just
went to go look for her
and she was there was when I lived in in
Carson so I took her home we hooked up
she listened to this day I can say that
was one of those [ __ ] she gave a
great great head and she's I go dude
you're [ __ ] she goes my mom taught me
I go what the [ __ ] she goes yeah she
said that's how you keep a guy I was
like what Wow all right why cheers to
your mom right
and so then uh so she she this is after
we hooked up she called her mom on her
cell phone and she goes you're never
gonna believe who I just hooked up with
his Eagle who she goes but being from
Caleb goes right into goes he goes I
can't you got it like that that's what
the mom said and I could and I'm like
keep his speaker [ __ ] out during
liquid hop forever and her day to build
her and her cousin is got a cousin I
used to go with her and uh but but and
I'll possible that chick recognize me
from the show as well and it was crazy
like she she shows up and she had tarot
cards and she's like hey I'm uh I'm
gonna is a cool if I read your tarot
cards and I think I borrowed your room
yeah I pick out one in the room and I
learned the bed and she reads me my
tarot cards no big deal and then she
goes there's one more card and as she
goes pick the card and then I put the
card down and she goes this card means
that it's time to turn off the lights
and you could do whatever you want
and then she turned off the lights and
it got dark as [ __ ] I was like wow and I
guy I fell in like we started you know
we hooked up and I had my hands on her
back and she was trembling and she was
hot like like like burning hot and I was
like what the [ __ ] I got like are you
sick it's like now I'm all paranoid like
I'm gonna catch something you know like
the okay she goes I just can't believe
I'm with out like what's up [ __ ] do you
know like what a rush that is and I'm
like thinking to myself I don't deserve
this I was telling myself you don't
deserve this bro
really Dom came on her too soon oh dude
that's what that [ __ ] told me
that day that week that I was on the
road he goes you want you're struggling
but it's not your fault because yours is
you're not ready rule it's my fault
I brought you too soon oh thank you
what a movie came out Amore's perros yes
that [ __ ] got other latina chicks crazy
bro and we with a chick named Gabby that
drew me much oh my god if it's not too
much trouble now online you bring your
homeboy tour yeah well medicinal walk
Liotta [ __ ] a week off of work
look you know do we have an envoy with a
branded combo we had no ride to meet
Gabriel at the area's gig and Rudy more
a dreamer endo and we had another gig
with ourselves when I'm still [ __ ]
bark at the moon gear but no no no that
wasn't that way when we will this chick
and with him we're talking to her bro I
know on the bed we just like she's on
the bed we're both hung up on the floor
like two cats looking at her talking to
her and I tried nothing I tried nothing
together at least anyway this will cause
a weary for no reason bro
hey brother chaser yeah bro hey bro put
some foam by her [ __ ] if you want to
talk to her a cock-blocker through the
four dogs oh my god that's [ __ ]
spawning bro that's it we picked a fly
bro in a real rose broke you were
looking like a [ __ ] that one was black
and sliced back yeah yeah that's it
you're saying we picked up a room you
told they put him up by the train
station but he had no right to get there
Wow
that's it that chick was a soldier
before she drove everywhere born and
then we she took
buddy plays house as she lived right
around there right and I'm sitting there
and I go hey if it's not too much
trouble
can we go all the way there be do it and
she was she signed up for one place
brawl is we were from place to place to
place and it was summer bro know like
hottest [ __ ] him she was just [ __ ]
cool Broyles take him back like those
days were like it was fun it was fun cuz
you didn't know any better I ain't know
what's gonna happen in the future
nothing you had no clue like hanging out
with I've been for a whole year just
smoking weed everyday and cruising
Silverlake ha ha ha what the [ __ ]
going on I mean that was all blazing we
chose we ate good huh hell yeah we're
all doing is eating chorizo at 2:00 in
the morning hell yeah
I remember man sub n slide yo grab any
minute he made me laugh when you got
both together and my ex-girlfriend 210
told you hey Martin yellow girlfriend
you said comedy is my girlfriend nice
and baby when I said yeah he's been
cheating on her man you all work
together how you it was you
G Riley I think Benny manna
we working at the mill at USC LA and so
comic that we hardly penny man I was
working at a your products FedEx FedEx
yeah I can't that chick named that he
was all brokenhearted with that chick he
couldn't get over Oh me and Benny used
to party bro is the party hung him me
him and bury me know where we were
hanging out at Dublin's at the one time
on Halloween and we said to walk around
with Hollywood that were Benny run into
an ex-member although I got pictures
from that night you know I was there
yeah you were just like a like a
hospital guy I think so but the four
years [ __ ] ever bro this one showed up
to Ibiza with Benny man ah
joker dressed like in costumes and no
one else was dressed up and when you're
home we'll had a guerilla caucus had a
full-on brawl a costume he saw was going
to wear the contest bro and I'm a
cartoon cat the evidence I just sitting
there like Harambee before he got shot
bro
a little shorter like a hospital guy and
my baby minute little chillin Hospital
guys and Joe Kalani walking guerrilla
dog that's inevitable dance you didn't
want to tell next year Brooke what are
you just pushing to really like you know
what sorry any questions oh my god how
do you mean Felipe yeah bro through
penny Manor how would that any let-up
Benny not when I pray that at all
no it was uh well coyote at pytheas uh
Benny when I stood Benny was the first
Latino comic I met I didn't know any
Latino comics when I first started doing
comedy I was doing comedy with Pat
labora bro and Bill word over in Orange
County
that's not good bye Eric nice house
dude he broke my forced by Oprah I was
like china dolls I was my credit bro I
like dude what movie is this when people
ask me because I don't worry everybody
was on china dolls I was like all right
okay sighs [ __ ] there's a bio with my
name attached to it that says I was on
china dolls and el matador by Joey
Medina
those were my movie credits bro this
dude would [ __ ] Pat would make he
could take an open mic er write a bio
that made it seem like this
[ __ ] been doing comedy his
entire life he cheated for slaughter in
high school ha ha ha ha ha tell our
publicist but um broke my femur and
broil it'll be crazy right when you were
on oh when I got off touring with you
guys and then you got when touring and I
keep party hard case whose house I would
end up on Fridays book that hot would
that white sheet used to live with
Tamara Tamara Wow I love like a week or
two
all right you go to her house with some
long hair food in Google Google what is
oh yes I was thank you so much I had to
go to her house I brought she was to
live she was still living in the
apartment building why everybody was
already kicked out she was the last one
there what I thought whole building is
empty she's the only apartment you know
it's crazy
I took a Tamara they shot out tomorrow
where before like when I started doing
comedy I took a class it was Bill words
comedy workshop at Harbor
and it was him and Justin as either
taught the class and Tamara was in the
class and she was the victor Anna that
had like done comedy before and I dunno
I had no nothing I don't know nothing
from nothing so those are the people
that I started off with Benny men I was
the first person that I met and I met
Benny at Dublin's and we just started
talking
it was comedy night when Jay Davis had
his show there so I was hanging out so
he shows up and he goes yeah I'm trying
to get booked I go your comment can he
goes I go holy [ __ ] goes yeah Jamie just
approved me to be a regular for Latino
night
dude I thought this guy's big like I
thought oh this guy's [ __ ] Wow like I
was like oh my god that's [ __ ] fun el
Shabab temple not peak with that now go
before you [ __ ] way or what you told us
it was your sisters waiting and you have
to throw a little speech anyway you're
still gonna wanna kiss you one or day I
said I said you know preordained yeah I
said great Jorge hey who does look like
[ __ ] and I be with you know came out of
it you know what a dictionary Hollywood
or no
25:26 oh yeah he's 20 scared kids right
yeah yeah I'm gonna fight him too soon
bro for that hahaha too soon like people
tell me all the time we aren't you can
cuz like michael t is super gray right
it's great great great great and then i
can i dr. greenthumb you should you
should you should dye it i'm like [ __ ]
that because you know the guys that
dialers guys are diet and it just looks
like they did the [ __ ] shoe polish
all right [ __ ] all right I'm like I can
sew right it tastes like a half hour to
get out of my seat but I can't forget I
go man [ __ ] do it like they got the
tiny mustache and they kind of continue
to [ __ ] oh ma bro you want to be like
[ __ ] you little bit Oscar dogs bark have
minestrone
I let it grow so that I could not shave
I don't need to do more chores I'm like
I shape the sides I did it for you guys
they didn't so other [ __ ] to promote the
Dollar Shave Club I shave the side but I
shave the sides once a week now like
once a week that's it but I was telling
her the biggest problem I have is eating
to shake it stuck in here so I'll do an
ice cream cone I had ice cream on here
and I liked it give me a napkin I got an
ice cream and I kind of wipe I go to the
gone and everybody's yeah yeah you can
see it no more than like I took two
steps on what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
I just grinded ice cream into this hair
I go special would have been in my head
I ever been a like I've been snapping
like I gotta wash this [ __ ] off I got
ice cream in here so it's construed it's
sticky and and and I'm like I still go
daughter people to see most people you
want to say ice cream a nice LZ they run
a covert office oh do like [ __ ] juices
right here on the Hawaii on the goatee
[ __ ] any conditioner at your phone
people do podcast it can you say that al
jibawi put the nobel apart can you get
just up nice hey listen but you know
what though you guys got cameras in sure
right yeah like I saw the one that you
guys did last week with the actor dude
here male 2 3 yeah big citric and I'm
like oh [ __ ] I told hooter man I got a
[ __ ] piranha I got is like it's not
like the radio no more are you used to
going to raid you're looking off beetle
but now everybody's got the [ __ ]
cameras and sure you two live
Oh everybody's [ __ ] streaming
everything like y'all know the cameras
are always on you like a night and I got
bad posture because like I'm usually
like this is [ __ ] like I got big old
titties so I'm like [ __ ] I got to sit
up straight I got to do this and I'm
right now I'm just like [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
like I'm seriously getting to the point
where I don't care anymore boy like when
I hear young people tell me no [ __ ]
given my shut the [ __ ] up you still give
a [ __ ] you you give a [ __ ] like you
really like like like when I say I used
to cheat I stopped well I stopped
cheating I I just tell people you never
know I do but I told her showed up when
I met her the first thing I said is like
listen I but you're [ __ ] awesome but
there's this chick in New Mexico who's a
great a seer I go there's no and I've
known her for [ __ ] years she and she
gets in there there's no way there's no
way you go
right yeah let's get in the videos are
from Tennessee can I set that I got a
flat out and she still figures it out so
anyway I go for colleges so now how do
you feel earn is a wonder where I'm
gonna be looks like to me forever
that's what when I was did he do like a
shark walking his team did I heard at
all George was doing some of the
approach
no there's what's it look like the
[ __ ] from Family Guy that all
sudden stood up from the wheelchair
awesome Ethel radiation [ __ ] Buzz
Lightyear a two wheel meet oh yeah I
heard that [ __ ] to blow everything you
told me about growing up in San Pedro
bro when I meet people from that area
near Alliance broker Wilmington die bro
I used to go to the crowbar bro that's
the wonderful shoulder with a bar eheh
what the all the vertical now the
[ __ ] um the seven I think it was the
seventy I ran across the street forever
yeah yeah the 720 say was the address of
the place but it started with the sex
buddy hope Anderson do shut up what a
[ __ ] body in the trunk bro and I used
to [ __ ] party there and do shots with
the phone with the owner every once in a
while it's a dude that place was [ __ ]
scanned it's still scandalous like when
I hear that Oh somebody got blasted and
blah blah blah there was a shooting and
and people make a big deal my
[ __ ] [ __ ] about uni
nobody made shooting somebody ever
mentions the shootings and [ __ ] weed
monster I shits on the regular bro we
were in a border town website like in a
like McAllen area or real I forgot one
of those [ __ ] border towns and
somebody that was with the one of the
sound guys was out at the market there
was a full-blown machine gun fight broke
in America in America side like machine
guns like this to say what the [ __ ] like
you could hear them freaking out and he
videotaped the whole [ __ ] thing that
[ __ ] never makes the news that's never
on the [ __ ] news put one foot in and
you know if its hood and it's right side
they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't blast you want to attention
you were a turban exactly you go yellow
there's no brown Longridge
so what's up bro you voted for Trump or
what no all right I did it would you get
it well you were vocal during your act
people tell you to calm down um I was I
wasn't [ __ ] here's the thing the
reality Felipe is that everybody's
pissed everybody's pissed but the the
poor people were pissed the rich people
are pissed the brown people are pissed
the [ __ ] the least earn are pissed
women are pissed my people what white
men are everywhere like they're being
attacked
white men feel like they're being
attacked women feel like they're being
attacked minorities feel like they're
being attacked everybody feels like
they're being attacked and they're
attacking each other as a consequence
the reality is that the [ __ ] on
the top are laughing all the way to the
bank
literally and we're over here fighting
over [ __ ] and and until everybody
wakes up and says these [ __ ] are the
ones that are [ __ ] us up and we need
to [ __ ] stick together instead of
[ __ ] keep on dividing ourselves and
and that's not the message that I
thought I was saying but what I did say
I did point out that the ridiculousness
of it which is that if Trump could run
and and and this was during the the
campaign I said then why the [ __ ] can I
run you know why can't I run it Sarah
Wilma anybody anybody anybody could run
at this point you're talking about Kayne
casting in his [ __ ] hat for president
everybody chose open really wants to run
for mayor of LA you know I mean and look
it's it's at this point every monkey is
out there like hey I'll run I'll do this
I'll do that but listen it is do it and
everybody's pissed that Trump I'm not a
Trump defender but here's the reality is
that I don't think Trump has the
capacity to draft all those executive
orders he's out there presenting [ __ ]
he's saying things and he's getting
people face not worries doing or doing
it's not what he's done it's what he's
gone nothing you know he knows what that
dude is I said was 3:00 in the morning
that [ __ ] say what the [ __ ] do
you know we're here to say they're like
born yesterday know it remember this
[ __ ] Chicano Studies bro what's that
bro Zack doesn't make you
dude bro without one bro what have you
done brother I think I got mad well it's
not what I've done it's what I'm gonna
do and you did a dog and you did it dog
gave it everything you were gonna do
everyone tell you told me I want to come
on in a movie like they say all badass
when I tell you enough fluffy video he
was gonna court or he [ __ ] he did it and
listen when I started this I said I want
to go to the Laugh Factory I want to I
want to perform like when all you need
credits for that and I know we'll even
so game with that too bro now ready dog
he told me now right
there's and like I said bro when he did
give me that advice that you shouldn't
put much because when I look back now at
the material of mine that's out there oh
my god like a local like a locals and
fur but kalapas you never you can find
those clips and it will find it yeah did
my set I've never found myself from
Caleb all the first joke is there a
method even ha god [ __ ] I we have
probably knows for everything it was
such a like I remember talking about the
[ __ ] the chick from that I make that
bet her dress I had a bunch of kids she
was like 20 and she like 10 kids and I
was supposed to go to her house and and
I got lost and I go I'm passing the
Macdonald she goes stop pick up ten
Happy Meals is just stupid [ __ ] like
that boy I did that I just [ __ ] so
pretty much you're pretty much I do it
like I was at home he's like eight that
took my pretty much on next thing you
know were kidnapped and [ __ ] Oxnard
I think we're doing lines Marin the
Quran I knows with this yeah what we're
doing lines in that garage shop for the
offender is a Harley though yes and he
won't turn it on yeah yeah kid to me
this is me cool yeah this is kill off
balls my god a [ __ ] kid hell are
aniele's Brielle oh my god for school
and I how big you look good woman look
at this huge dog theater tours I got in
I got in the last season of Gale opposed
and and this is this is how responsible
a number everybody auditioned I didn't
go to the [ __ ] audition everybody
sent tapes like when the people tell me
today a I need you to mail me something
bro I it it's I don't know why it's so
difficult for me to get to a [ __ ]
post office the thing will be sitting
there already ready packaged
got a ghost drop that [ __ ] off
and I just don't I don't know I
procrastinate I put it off and and so
and I think that but that makes me a
little lazy I guess right but I didn't I
didn't audition I remember they had
auditions at an audition I did
additional 50s I remember that and
everybody bombed my roebling's oh yeah
well nobody has a list somewhere and
then and then I remember [ __ ] they
send tapes I didn't have a tape and all
of a sudden I was driving home from from
work I was driving home and I had a
pager do this before cellphones got a
pager beeping yeah it starts beeping and
it's a trio it's a New York number and
it was Roger Paul I didn't know it was
Roger Paul I pulled over off the 405
found a payphone like now you [ __ ]
kidding me my cell phone rings I don't
pick it up back then the page would go
off you go find a payphone you know how
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know how lazy we
become bro
and so I got off the freeway I find I
called and he goes hey it's Roger
polygon hey what's up and he goes
so we're filming and it was late already
Broyles were filming at the ice or
Pasadena
he goes do you have ten minutes you can
do it I was like or six minutes whatever
the [ __ ] it was and I was like [ __ ] yeah
he goes yeah Philippe and Gabe were put
in a good word for you so we need
somebody I guess somebody had fallen off
and I was like I sped home I [ __ ] put
on my [ __ ] party or pants I had those
pads that looked like so feature this
grey pants and a black shirt I still
remember what I wore and the black
leather jacket and I went on stage
before I went on stage I was drinking
water outside and Gabriel was talking to
Mike Robles and I remember my water fell
from my hand and my father look at him
he's getting nervous and I was like [ __ ]
and then like I would like me Bates no I
remember going up there and I was
nervous my mouth was dry
I'm I kept licking my lips but it was a
good set I had a decent set and it was
already poss-eye
and turns out it was the only episode it
was me
Thea Vidale Bobby Lee and gene pompa and
Mike Robles hosted that show and that
was the only episode that microbrews
hosted that season so they played the
[ __ ] out of that it was the last season
Mike Robles is only episode that he
hosted and they play
the [ __ ] out of that episode and I
remember when it aired
I was hoping uh that weekend it because
I used to are on Thursday and that
weekend I was helping Reuben King time I
move he was packing up all his [ __ ] had
to suck it had the vibrator [ __ ]
jumping around in the trash gun but he
was at a Christian chick by this time so
it was trying to hide it and McKenna
he's the battery day right and so and so
then I get another text from larger Paul
and and it's it's to whether I would
know I don't know the text or if I had a
cell phone by then and it was for the
[ __ ] tour that cuz I guess somebody
had fallen off the tour and they need a
buddy
Willie though yeah bring those wrestling
injury and actor Willie and I remember I
had at that time I had a suspended
license
I had expired tags and I had a big-ass
blue truck bro and I remembered that he
goes can you be in San Diego tonight for
the tour Spreckels on at the Spreckels
theater and I was like yeah and I
[ __ ] you know I told Ruben April I
gotta go I'm gonna go and that that was
Roger Palmer to do the tour and I could
tell he was like what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] gonna do it and so I went I
went to and I went home and I put on the
exact same outfit the exact same outfit
I remember going into the theater and
and people hey that's like I didn't know
I didn't know [ __ ] from Adam bro and I
was who are the regulars you're crazy
they and I when people came out after
that show and they wanted to take
pictures and they wanted out I forgot an
open mic er I'm pretty much a [ __ ]
open Micro at this time and and
everybody's like they had seen me on TV
on arguably the hottest show of the time
and and and for the first five minutes
it was all like like like you know when
you're on LSD and everything looks like
[ __ ] like you're in a whole different
dimension and it's all these lights
that's what it felt like it I wasn't
even like I wasn't even there like it
was like I was like like like in a whole
different place like it was very [ __ ]
surreal and it was just like what the
[ __ ] and to get that kind of like
attention that quick
you
get a little delusional you get a little
like yeah [ __ ] y'all
how dare you tell me I'm not ready to
put this [ __ ] on TV talking hey you're
just looking hating because you didn't
get these opportunities but it was
inertia and I got to tell you I got to
tell you a lot of that [ __ ] was because
of you and Gabriel I mean you guys
opened up a [ __ ] ton of doors you're but
not just for me but for a lot of people
for a lot of the comedian's there was a
lot of guys that that were [ __ ] to
people and you guys were like hey you
know what [ __ ] this guy's funny this
guy's funny let's help him out you
[ __ ] got me a gig at the force
and B bro it was like a theater I
remember I I was I don't know what I was
adored they wanted me to do twenty and
twenty or some or ten or one of us is my
room I know the romanesque I did my I
took G Riley with me I'm everywhere in
the green room and Joe Riley girl O'Shea
you [ __ ] around and got a real gig it
was me him and the chick I was dating at
the time we all shared a room [ __ ] they
were all happy bro
and I was listen when we went to [ __ ]
when I went to the Spreckels I was like
we got lost
first of all we got lost we went to the
wrong hotel I'm trying to bleep and I'm
like no it's this way I just got there
are no [ __ ] hotels but for some
reason these [ __ ] followed meals it
was you and you I think and I think I
was like [ __ ] it where I'm just gonna
knock out on the floor and then I think
one of you guys said now you have a bad
day you performed but I figured [ __ ]
these guys have been here for a long
time I wasn't I never felt like I was
entitled like I never felt like oh I
deserve this because I'm on there's
[ __ ] I walk around like kind of
that and I was like hey I'm just I was
happy I was there and those guys had
been there you guys had been there way
before I [ __ ] got there so it's just
like a bouquet
I need somebody give me a pillow I'll
[ __ ] crash right here I was I just
done the [ __ ] Spreckels theater I got
a picture on that same collage I got a
picture of the Spreckels sign that says
gay loafers hell yeah yeah that one's
over
dirty for long after I got I remember I
was with him when we got pulled over and
a [ __ ] cop knew the expired tags new
girl has a license knew all of that and
how he let him go were you told a copy
or a marine or some shitty let you go I
was crazy those [ __ ] Rambo yeah I'm
going legit back with me and I've died I
was left at the wild goose for always
followed by LAX it was a strip club and
we got fogged up we got [ __ ] up and I
went outside for something and when I
try to get back in that guy goes loose
your idea go dude I was already in here
and he goes we see your ID so I kill my
ID and it goes there's a fake ID and he
took it away from me and I was like
that's my [ __ ] ID right and he goes
nope - fake ID and he took and I'll get
out [ __ ] up and I remember I was like
[ __ ] this I call I go out there I called
9-1-1 from a payphone bro and I go hey
man like a [ __ ] Club I like this
freaking Club and the security guard
stole my ID he stole my [ __ ] ID and
they're like what but I mean they stole
your idea go toaster see I stole my idea
I mean my that's my license I can't ride
without my license about an hour later
bro and I waited brows I had nowhere to
go am I gonna go
I forgot and I waited the cops showed up
the sheriff showed up right and then I
had a I had a Marine Corps sure I didn't
go in the Marines for like two months I
can tell us as I so I had a shirt that
said Marine Corps and back then I was
fit and I was still shaving my head on
the sides because people buy me drinks
did I go for that you shake I'm yeah i
milk that [ __ ] for [ __ ] months after
I came back from boot camp and for again
um the the circles so what happened I go
they took my ID and it goes are you a
Marine I go sir yes sir
like I'm [ __ ] he goes ok we were in
the [ __ ] car
Jackie I thought it was [ __ ] awesome
right and then all my friends are
liberals me Jake Mario Worf we've been
there all day [ __ ] it looks like
[ __ ] five dollar pictures or
something stupid right and the cop goes
who took this I took the driver's
license from this marine and then I
looked at who's him
[Laughter]
giggles keep looking and goes give this
marine back his identification and I
think there he goes but they're cut off
they have to go as we go so he walks us
out and he goes I swear to god takes us
to the car right and it's Jake's car and
he goes he goes how you guys getting
home and we'll just car
we're [ __ ] late any and but I'm
standing up I'm being [ __ ] a I'm
being like rational as he goes so he
goes it takes the keys from Jake and he
goes here we go marine get these men
home safe for example I swear to god
[ __ ] car - no gift of gavel here dog
you take a murder but to be able rocky
turn 80 men oh [ __ ] okay now when I
started a bad color tunic apocalypse a
national food podcast with a very
awesome guest hopefully we'll have a bad
hell yeah my only source or surface is
Korea right here when I check out me and
who are - Martine and her martini with a
neighbor oh my gosh we're on the podcast
wonder what Tuesday night Tuesday's we
record Monday night vision what we do
bro we [ __ ] record up the pad and we
[ __ ] just we have people over we make
food we throw a little party and then we
in this full talk right and because I
need the energy from the people but
otherwise I feel like what the [ __ ] man
if I don't listening as a comic you just
the actors they don't give a [ __ ] nobody
could be in there and they'll make
themselves cry me I need somebody to
give me feedback homes I hate was in you
know unless I'm jacking off then I could
do that solo but everything else when
I'm performing I need feedback right but
so Martine and hooter podcast and then
our July 7th
magic appleís in Santa Monica - June
29th Eastside love in Boyle Heights and
Eventbrite if you search marketing
Mourinho you'll find the ticket and like
I said don't ask me to hook you up the
only ten [ __ ] bucks come support art
because that's what it is bro it's art
it's I think that what comedians do is
[ __ ]
are you know to go up there and and and
and how whatever level of performance
you do it's still your art you know when
you make it your your own and and you
start speaking your own truth it took me
many years to figure out what that was I
was out there just passing up [ __ ]
tossing up things that no Shah Baba did
anything that I thought was funny you
know like I remember I've been said to
me one time I said April how does this
outfit look and I go can I pull this off
and it goes [ __ ] you could pull
off a clown suit
he goes I go that's [ __ ] funny cuz
your cell phone would ring you'd be like
Hong Kong of my cell phone [ __ ] good I
went up on that there is a ringtone of
me saying that people probably think all
this [ __ ] racist [ __ ] because this is
honk honk that's my cell phone there
that's my ringtone bros out there
Joel put that out there somewhere play
online plethora of information worse oh
did you fill up that big an application
I told you about you get your money no
you haven't done I didn't I told you but
I can't even get to a post office worth
coming in later on after year let me
know I always change SoundExchange
that I probably have something I'm
pretty sure that we did with the guy
from XM yes back in DC yes he put it out
there so it's on I think I'm on [ __ ]
Pandora it's been on now for you I guess
they owe you like seven years of
royalties stop yeah my first check I
kiddin I were to $2,500 how long ago was
that that was like 25 years five years
ago Wow I showed everything out to know
when your stuff played from that one
time it played on Pandora a prism XM it
plays on Sirius it'll play like a public
cloud Pony somewhere wherever it is if
you please they'll find it and you'll
get your money that's so [ __ ] crazy
cuz you know what's funny is III when I
listened to those sets from from way
back in the day I cringe but I'm like oh
like I can't stand listening to my
algebra
oh yeah Romano's and Ruben every
Wednesday night at 8 p.m.
Romano's in Riverside downtown Riverside
and Hulu we're gonna be really show
coming up here Mike on the 29th I'll be
San Jose on the 28th down there low 28
Chuck our maretto man yeah man I don't
want any food hanging out with her but
Tempe Arizona Senate [ __ ] cook a hot
dog bro I walked away a little bedroom
oh my god he walks away with the [ __ ]
mic were on fire starter that hot dog no
one who that was around her jeepers oh
poor guy tortured hooter as a kitty okay
I just [ __ ] up with a brilliant
province before you knew out of like
with egg lay before you stole a car from
your mom you [ __ ] or drive me home if
I'm loaded it feels like designated
driver man man you tell my comedy man
we'll get the next time I see Mike also
revisited was their wedding yeah man
gable married oh and up and then I
mentioned man you know you can get to
what with the wife and your home for
your history this your husband
oh [ __ ] I got married at the ice house
yeah absolute old weddings are so cool a
big help for my team Orlando Magic model
you with your Twitter Martin comic
Martin comic everything is my thing
comic except for Facebook my thing comic
is Martin Rizal when I wrote it I got at
Comic Martine and hooter hooter Mareno
hecho ter berrendo yeah yeah man like I
require right here Mac Wailord
yeah man hey thank you guys for having
me seriously I have a comic in time and
those funnels nothing I love you bro
they're gonna be looking USC Mortimer
Leno support his show at the head and
one man short at the East I love you say
you know why I got Rafa hanging out bro
oh there's no rule you don't grow in
Sacramento that we do it's a beauty